when you think about nothing you have to
be a little more careful than you
normally are because in fact nothing is
a physical concept because it's the
absence of something and something is a
physical concept and what we've learned
over the last hundred years is that
nothing is much more complicated than we
would have imagined otherwise for
example the simplest kind of nothing is
the kind of nothing of the Bible save
you an infinite empty space an infinite
Dark Void of the Bible you know nothing
in it no particles no radiation nothing
well that kind of nothing turns out to
be full of stuff in a way or at least
much more complicated than you might
have imagined because due to the laws of
quantum mechanics and relativity we now
know that empty space is a boiling
bubbling brew of virtual particles that
are popping in and out of existence at
every moment and in fact for that kind
of nothing if you wait long enough
you're guaranteed by the laws of quantum
mechanics to produce something so the
difference between empty space with
stuff in it and empty space with nothing
in it is not that great anymore in fact
there are different versions of the same
thing so the transition from nothing to
something is not so surprising now you
might say oh that's not good enough
because you have space where did the
space come from well this a more
demanding definition of nothing is no
space but in fact once you apply the
laws of quantum mechanics to gravity
itself that space itself becomes a
quantum mechanical variable and
fluctuates in and out of existence and
you can literally by the laws of quantum
mechanics create universes create spaces
and times where there is no space and
time before so now you've got no
particles no radiation no space no time
that sounds like nothing but then you
might say well you know what you got the
laws of physics got the laws of nature
the laws themselves are somehow
something although I would argue in fact
that is not at all obvious or clear or
necessary but even there it turns out
physics potentially as an answer because
we now have good reason to believe that
even the laws of physics themselves are
kind of arbitrary there may be an
infinite number of universes and in each
universe that's been created the laws of
physics are different it's completely
random and the laws themselves come into
existence when the universe comes into
existence so there's no pre-existing
fundamental law anything that can happen
does happen
and that therefore you got no laws no
space no time no particles no radiation
that's a pretty good definition of
nothing